hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of our readers dedi who is a PR
consultant at a hospital and he put
together a plan to help market the
hospital and get some media attention to
get new customers coming in the plan was
rejected and now months later it's come
back they said they want to implement it
but didn't have the time to do it and he
wanted my advice on what he should do so
daddy it sounds like the the company
you're working for isn't really
committed to the strategies and there
they may be hoping for some really fast
results and so you need to watch
carefully that you can manage
expectations so they're not going to get
immediate results and if they're not
committed to it they could have some
problems and that could impact your job
security as well because you didn't
deliver on what was supposed to be this
big plan so in terms of managing
expectations what i would do is lay out
my plan for what they can expect over
the next say six months and next year
maybe three months six months in and
year as you kind of roll out your
strategy and let them know what they can
expect and if they can you know do this
for a year afterwards then here's what
we can expect so you can kind of manage
what they think is going to happen so
then when results come in they're not
terribly disappointed but it does sound
like they're not super committed to this
and there may be some issues on going
with them and something to think about
for your own self as well if you're not
getting the support and your company
they're not recognizing your talents
then maybe it's time to look for either
another job or start you're bitten your
own business as well and hopefully some
of these videos might help you kind of
get off the ground with that so I hope
that was helpful daddy for everybody
watching love to hear you have to say if
you won't leave a comment under the
video and if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up I always appreciate
those makes me want to do more of these
videos so thank you and see you on the
next episode
you
you